foreign
[Music]
Google today with my friend Brendan
we're going to show you how the new web
GPU API unlocks massive performance
gains in graphics and machine learning
workloads but first let's provide some
context on why web GPU was developed in
2011 webgl came out which allows web
applications to take advantage of gpus
webgl has enabled amazing experiences on
the web from Google Earth to interactive
music videos to 3D real estate
walkthroughs and more webgl was based on
the opengl family of API first developed
in 1992 and that's a long time ago I
barely knew how to walk back then and
you can imagine that GPU Hardware has
evolved significantly since that time so
to keep up with the evolution there was
a new breed of native apis that have
been developed to more efficiently
interact with modern gpus apis like
direct 3d12 metal and Vulcan these new
apis have supported new and demanding
use cases for GPU programming like the
explosion in machine learning and even
more advances in rendering algorithms
web GPU is the successor to webgl which
brings the advancement of this new class
of modern apis to the web web GPU
unlocks a lot of new GPU programming
possibilities in the browser it both
better reflects how modern GPU Hardware
works and it lays a foundation on which
we can build even more advanced GPU
capabilities in the future the API has
been baking in the w3c GPU for the web
group since 2017 and is a collaboration
between many companies such as Apple
Google Mozilla Microsoft and Intel
and now after six years of hard work
we're excited to announce that one of
the biggest additions to the web
platform is finally available web GPU is
available today in Chrome 113 on Chrome
OS Mac OS and windows with other
platforms coming soon a huge thank you
to other chromium contributors and Intel
in particular who helped make this
happen now let's take a look at some of
the exciting use cases that web GPU
enables
[Music]
web GPU features such as compute shaders
enable new class of algorithms to be
ported on the GPU for example algorithms
that can add more Dynamic details to the
scene simulate physical phenomenons and
more and there are even workloads that
previously could only be done in
JavaScript that can now be moved to the
GPU this demonstration shows the
marching Cube algorithm being used to
triangulate the surface of these
metabols
the algorithm when it's running in
JavaScript struggles to keep up with the
page only running at 8 FPS which results
in janky animation
to keep it performant we would have to
lower the level of details a lot
it's night and day difference when we
move the CM algorithm to a computer the
performance improves dramatically with
the page now running at a smooth 60fps
and there's still a lot of performance
Headroom for other effects
in addition the Page's main JavaScript
Loop is completely freed up for other
tasks ensuring that interactions with
the page stay responsive
web GPU also enables complex visual
effects that were not practical before
in this example created in the popular
babylon.js Library the ocean surface is
being simulated entirely on the GPU the
realistic Dynamics are created from many
independent waves being added to each
other but simulating each wave directly
would be too expensive that's why the
demo uses an advanced algorithm called
Fast Fourier transform
instead of representing all the waves as
complex positional data we can work with
the spectral data which is much more
efficient to perform computations
then each frame we use the Fourier
transform to convert from spectral data
to the positional data that represents
the height of the waves
web GPU is also useful to accelerate
machine learning which has become a
major use of gpus in recent years for a
long time creative developers have been
repurposing webgl's rendering API to
perform non-rendering operations such as
machine learning computations however
this requires drawing the pixels of
triangles as a way to initiate the
computation and carefully packing and
unpacking tensor data in textures
instead of more general purpose memory
accesses it requires developers to
awkwardly conform their code to the
expectations of an API designed only for
drawing combined with the lack of basic
features like shared memory accesses
between computations this lead to
duplicate work and sub-optimal
performance computers are web gpu's
primary new feature and remove these
pain points compute shaders offer a more
flexible programming model that takes
advantage of the gpu's massively
parallel nature while not being
constrained by the strict structure of
rendering operations
this gives more opportunity for sharing
data and computation results within
groups of Shader work for better
efficiency this can lead to significant
gains over previous attempts to use
webgl for the same purpose
as an example of the efficiency gains
this can bring an initial Port of an
image diffusion model in tensorflow.js
shows a 3X performance gain on a variety
of Hardware when moved from webgl to web
GPU on some Hardware we tested the image
can be rendered in under 10 seconds and
because this was an early Port we
believe there are even more improvements
possible in both web GPU and
tensorflow.js
if you're interested in advances in web
machine learning and tensorflow.js be
sure to check out the what's new with
webml in 2023 session you'll find the
link in the description
but web GPU is not about just bringing
GPU features to the web
[Music]
hey I'm Brandon one of the specification
editors for web GPU the features that
enable these use cases have been
available to Native Developers for a
while
and it's been our challenge to expose
them in a way that feels like a natural
part of the web platform
web GPU was developed with the benefit
of hindsight from over a decade of
developers doing amazing work with webgl
we were able to take the problems they
encountered the bottlenecks they hit and
the issues they raised and funnel all of
that feedback into this new API
we saw that webgl's Global State model
made creating robust composable
libraries and applications difficult and
fragile
so web GPU dramatically reduces the
amount of state that developers need to
keep track of while sending commands to
the GPU
we heard that debugging webgl
applications was a pain
so web GPU includes a more flexible
error handling mechanism that doesn't
tank your performance and we've gone out
of our way to ensure that every message
you get back from the API is easy to
understand and actionable
we also saw that frequently the overhead
of making too many JavaScript calls was
a bottleneck for complex webgl
applications as a result the web GPU API
is less chatty so you can accomplish
more with fewer function calls we focus
on performing heavyweight validation up
front keeping the critical draw loop as
lean as possible and we offer new apis
like render bundles
which allow you to record large numbers
of drawing commands in advance and
replay them with a single call
to demonstrate what a dramatic
difference a feature-like render bundles
can make here's another demo from
Babylon Js
their webgl to renderer can execute all
of the JavaScript calls to render this
Art Gallery scene at about 500 times a
second which is pretty good
their web GPU renderer however enables a
feature they call snapshot rendering
built on top of web gpu's render bundles
this feature allows the same scene to be
submitted more than 10 times faster
this significantly reduced overhead
allows web GPU to render more complex
scenes while also allowing applications
to do more with JavaScript in parallel
modern Graphics apis have a reputation
for complexity
trading Simplicity for extreme
optimization opportunities web GPU on
the other hand is focused on
cross-platform compatibility
handling traditionally difficult topics
like resource synchronization
automatically in most cases
this has the happy side effect the web
GPU is easy to learn and use
it relies on existing features of the
web platform for things like image and
video loading and leans into well-known
JavaScript patterns like promises for
asynchronous operations
this helped keep the amount of
boilerplate code needed to a minimum
you can get your first triangle on
screen in under 50 lines of code
[Music]
it's exciting to see all the new
possibilities that web GPU brings to the
web platform and we're looking forward
to seeing all of the cool new use cases
that you will find for web GPU a vibrant
ecosystem of libraries and Frameworks
has been built around webgl and that
same ecosystem is eager to embrace web
GPU support for web GPU is in progress
or already complete in many popular
JavaScript webgl libraries and in some
cases taking advantage of the benefits
of web GPU may be as simple as changing
a single flag and this first release in
Chrome 113 is just a start while our
initial release is for Windows Chrome OS
and Mac OS we plan to bring web GPU to
the remaining platforms like Android and
Linux in the near future and it's not
just the Chrome team that's been working
on launching web GPU
implementations are also in progress in
Firefox and webkit as well additionally
new features are already being designed
at the w3c that can be exposed when
available in Hardware
for example
in Chrome we plan to enable support for
16-bit floating Point numbers and
shaders and the dp4 class of
instructions soon these will enable even
more machine learning performance
improvements web GPU is an extensive API
that unlocks amazing performance if you
invest in it
today we could only cover its benefits
at a high level
but if you'd like to get a Hands-On
start with web GPU
please check out our introductory code
lab your first web GPU app where you'll
build a GPU version of the classic
Conway's Game of Life
this code lab will walk you through the
process step by step so you can try it
out even if it's your first time doing
GPU development
a link to the code lab can be found in
the description
the web GPU samples are also a good
place to get a feel for the API they
range from the traditional hello
triangle to more complete rendering and
compute pipelines demonstrating a
variety of techniques
and by the way as some of our more
observant viewers may have noticed these
samples aren't running in Chrome
it's actually a pre-release version of
web GPU support in Firefox nightly that
our friends at Mozilla have been hard at
work on
we were able to get these samples
running in their implementation with
only a few minor modifications and
expect that even those won't be
necessary soon
finally the web GPU article on
developers.chrome.com Linked In the
description
contains all the links from this talk
and pointers to tutorials mdn
documentation samples and more
so please
try out web GPU
[Music]